[Music]  good evening  welcome to hawthorne it'll be our  pleasure to feed you tonight will be  magical  over the next few hours you will ingest  fat  salt  protein  and at times entire ecosystems we're  eating the ocean we're eating the ocean  are you crying  [Music]  it's just i find it all very moving so  it's okay but i'm not as into this as  you are  oh my god  you shouldn't be here tonight  you my dear guests  are not the common man isn't that right  is he gonna keep doing that what happens  inside this room is meaningless compared  to what happens outside  we are about a frightened nanosecond  nature is timeless  what the hell is going on  i love you all  any questions  is this bergamot i'm getting chef  yes it is  [Music]  [Music]  you